el crecimiento de uranio iraní al 83,7%
prende las alarmas del organismo
internacional de energía atómica en un
informe reporta que el país superó la
Barrera del 60% de pureza aunque aún no
se sabe si es posible que haya un error
en la medición como lo dijo Julián
gadano director de energía política y
seguridad nuclear de la fundación
Argentina global para Franz 24
técnicamente efectivamente tratarse de
una fluctuación pero dada las las
digamos la poca transparencia que Irán
está mostrando últimamente en sus
operaciones de enriquecimiento es
importante que la audiencia entienda que
enriquecimiento significa aumentar la
proporción de disoto 235 del uranio que
es el isótopo fionable es decir el
necesario para hacer
bombas el uranio tal cual está en la en
la naturaleza en la cantidad del
porcentaje de vistos 235 es muy baja hay
que aumentarla de manera artificial
con casi el 84% Teherán estaría apenas
por debajo del 90 requerido para una
bomba atómica bajo la cuerda de 2015 que
el entonces presidente de Estados Unidos
Donald Trump abandonó en 2018 Irán había
frenado su programa nuclear a cambio de
un alivio de las sanciones económicas
pero Trump volvió a imponerlas e Irán
retomó el enriquecimiento pero es un
acuerdo que no está en vigencia y ahí
hay alguna responsabilidad también del
gobierno anterior de los Estados Unidos
que queriendo endurecer se retira del
acuerdo Entonces eso le abrió a mi
juicio muy subjetivo Y opinable por
supuesto pero a mi juicio Estados Unidos
comete un error ahí error que está
tratando de enmendar la actual
administración porque al abrirse del
acuerdo los Estados Unidos le abrieron
la puerta a Irán para que Irán se fuera
del acuerdo el gobierno de biden ha
intentado reactivar el pacto de los dos
últimos años pero no lo ha conseguido
Alemania e Israel mostraron preocupación
por la elevada cifra del uranio
enriquecido en